كاهن يقود الصلاة في كنيسة مؤقتة
لاجئون إريتريون في ليبيا
غرباء إنهم في أرض غريبة
وقعوا في حرب ليست من صنعهم
لأن اليوم هو يوم الأحد الذي
رسموا فيه أيقوناتهم الخاصة صنعوا
صليب المصور المستقل غابرييل
العار تمكنوا من الوصول إلى هذا الاحتجاز
مركز يضم حوالي 900 شخص في
ضواحي العاصمة طرابلس معظمهم
من اللاجئين والمهاجرين من
أفريقيا جنوب الصحراء الكبرى ، تحذر الأمم المتحدة من
أن أكثر من 5000 مهاجر
ولاجئ ومراكز مماثلة في
طرابلس في خطر حيث أصبحت المدينة
ساحة معركة بين  الحكومات المتنافسة
في أبريل / نيسان مسلحون مع ما يسمى
بالجيش الوطني الليبي بقيادة أمير الحرب
حليفة كفتة اقتحموا أحد
مراكز الاحتجاز جنوب طرابلس ،
والصور التي سجلها شهود العيان
تنقل بوضوح الفوضى والمجازر ، حيث تسبب إطلاق النار
في مقتل
رجلين وإصابة ما يقرب من 36.
يتذكر آخرون سامي من إريتريا ما حدث
[موسيقى]
هذه
لم نفتحها
من قبل  لقد تم نقل السكان
إلى أرض أكثر أمانًا ، لكن البعض لا
يزال يعاني من جروح مفتوحة من ذلك الهجوم ، ربما يكون
آلاف المهاجرين المحاصرين الآن في
ليبيا هم الأشخاص الأكثر ضعفًا في العالم
الذين تقطعت بهم السبل في أرض في
حالة حرب حيث يبدو أن تجار البشر وتجار العبيد
يتمتعون بالحرية
لن تستقبلهم أوروبا وسيواجه الكثيرون
الاضطهاد أو الموت إذا عادوا إلى ديارهم
هنا ، تبخر لبن اللطف البشري
زكريا عبد الله من دارفور. يقول السودان
إن الخوف من عدم اليقين والحرمان قد أوقعت
خسائر في عيون هؤلاء
الناس كيف حالهم؟  كيف
تبدو الحلقة لأن هناك القليل من الاستنزاف
، لا يوجد علاج طبي جيد ،
لا توجد مياه جيدة ، لا يوجد طعام ،
لقد رأينا كذبة تعيش فقط
، يقول محمد حافظ البالغ من العمر 21 عامًا
أيضًا من دارفور لديه تذكير بسيط
لأي شخص لن يستمع لأي
شخص ولكن هذا كان ينتظر CNN
Bailey